thank you kendall all right it is time
to check in with the may brigade as they
continue to fight off
mess dirt and germs for our community
take a look
[Music]
we've been to your clients homes we've
been to one of your commercial
properties and now we see
where it all starts we're here at your
office welcome to the most exciting
place in las vegas
we have about 25 ladies that come in and
out of here on a regular basis
we got about 11 of these guys that are
getting gassed up
getting equipped getting basically
getting ready to go out into the field
so what happens when your mates actually
enter the homes how does it work
it depends on the customer's wants and
needs as far as how we get into a house
i'd say large part of our customers are
giving us keys to their homes
or garage pads or these days they have
the schlog locks where they have a code
and they can actually remotely unlock
them but those are the main ways people
get us in and out
a lot of customers do prefer that they
be home for whatever reason they have
pets and
they want to take care of them or just a
safety issue that's fine as well
we just clean around them but that's
basically what we do and we just get in
the house and do our thing
well how long does it take the average
house maybe 2 000 square feet it's going
to take us about an hour and 45 minutes
to clean
every two weeks and that's kind of our
average how do you keep your pet secure
when when maids are entering and exiting
we have about 300 customers at least 280
of them have pets they have cats they
have dogs we have turtles birds
you name it basically what i tell people
is you need to do what you need to do to
make sure that you feel safe
your pet feels safe and secure if you
need us to be part of that process then
we need to be instructed on
what to do you know do we let them in
and out of a crate or do we put them in
the backyard or bring them in the
backyard with the hot summer months
coming in
we just need to be instructed i feel
like there's a lot of trust between
the community and maybe there is i mean
we've been around las vegas for
for 15 years i mean this this i feel
like
our customers and and this business is
more of a relationship
more so than necessarily a business if
you will
what i feel makes us one of the best in
the valley
really is our is our company culture and
it starts
at the top but it in the middle is the
field staff
and the employees are what makes the
world go round at maid brigade and what
about product wise
i understand you guys have some pretty
we do big technology here it's exciting
to me
we have a machine in our office that
actually creates all of our own
cleaning products on-site generation
it's called it's called the orbio
and it creates electrolyzed water which
is what we clean about 80
of our homes with we do actually use
bars keepers friend as well
which would be a comet replacement it's
also a green product it's actually made
out of volcanic ash
and we use traditional dish soap but for
the most part we're cleaning everything
with our electrolyzed water we bring in
state of the art triple hepa filtered
vacuum
all our mops everything color-coded
towels you name it
so basically you can sit there and watch
tv we clean the house
we should be an afterthought for you so
in addition to thanking all the las
vegas valley
and all of our employees we want to
thank our mothers and give a mother's
day promotion
we're doing 300 off of a cleaning if you
go to maidbrigade.com and you put in
your zip code
and go to the contact us page tell us
why your mom deserves 300
free cleanings and if you're the winner
we'll reach out to you
great promotion right there check them
out at maidbrigade.com and in
celebration as you said of mother's day
that's where you can enter
for a chance to win 300 off of a
cleaning for your mom
we'll be right back